all right welcome everyone to our next
episode of dc thursday i'm pete um it's
great to have you with us
we've had a lot of great guests over the
past couple months as we've
launched these events this summer and uh
i'm very excited to have
our guest today who's been a friend for
many years from the data community
wes mckinney and i actually met during
some really
odd circumstances in new york city
there was a multi-day power outage in
what was it 2012 maybe 2012 yeah
2012 there was a multi-day power outage
in new york city
i didn't have any power in my apartment
and a data friend from the community
connected me with wes and i literally
slept on wes
couch um in williamsburg and that's
when we first started to talk about work
you were doing on pandas and other
things so
that's just a funny little um anecdote
but um wes has been a good friend
and obviously a known figure in the data
science community
and so i'm really excited to have you
wes thanks for joining us
thanks for uh thanks for having me on
the on the
show or podcast or videocast yeah the
stream
yeah awesome it's a it's a live stream
with a live community questions so we'll
get to those
uh in a minute but i just wanted to call
out um some of the great work that
you've done
wes i think most folks are probably
familiar with you from
pandas as i mentioned you've also wrote
a book python for data analysis
published by o'reilly and then more
recently
you started a company called ursa labs
which i know
is the entity supporting your work on
apache arrow
which we'll talk about a bunch today so
obviously those are some great
credentials and
lots of folks in the community know you
um i also wanted to mention
just as sort of a background um in case
folks aren't as familiar with arrow
which a bunch of our conversation today
will be about
um arrow has been around since 2006
um you've had eight sorry 2016
uh four years you've had 18
major releases of the language or the
the library um 500 unique contributors
50 million in package installs in 2019
uh 52 committers and 29 pmc members and
11
programming languages represented so
arrow has become
a bit of a thing in the background i
know it doesn't necessarily have the
same representation
in the way users use it as pandas does
so it might not get the same visibility
but we're going to talk a lot about aero
today and
i'm excited to hear you sound off on
sort of what's new with the library
how arrow is used and what it can be
great for
so um wes just to kick things off i know
you had a major release
in the last a couple months the aero
1.0.0 release
um considering that the package has been
around for so many years
um what's the significance of this
release and talk us a little bit through
that
sure um well the the 1.0 release is the
first
um the first release that we've declared
to be formally
stable from uh from a binary
um uh from a binary uh protocol level
point of view so we we've been working
the last four and a half years
to develop the aero columnar data format
to build
libraries in multiple languages that
implement the format
and developing you know kind of working
out all of the
the fine details of how uh you know how
the format works how we
transport it between between languages
and systems
how we serialize it how we write it to
files on disk
uh how we can move it over move it over
tcp like send large data sets in a
streaming fashion
um and we also wanted to you know given
that the arrow was very much a chicken
and egg problem where
um you know people need to take spend
some time with it before they're able to
give
substantive feedback about what it does
and what it what it does well and what
it doesn't do well
so we wanted to take like a good period
of time like a pretty long period of
time to
allow people to show up and provide
feedback about the project because
as we start committing to things being
stable it becomes more and more
difficult to change things and so
we decided that you know initially we
thought we might have been able to
to make a like the arrow format has been
for all practical purposes stable since
the end of 2017
so for almost three years um that was
the last time we made like a
a disruptive uh you know non-backward
compatible
compatible change but we we didn't want
to declare it stable
and close the door to making you know
potentially breaking changes in case
some people came out of the woodwork and
found some problem with
the format that they we need to change
something that would be
a significant benefit uh to the project
so
we also um a big part of the the 1.0
release was that we completed
a significant amount of compatibility
testing between some of the major
implementations so between the c
plus library and the java library we
have really comprehensive
protocol level integration tests that
compare
data payloads like essentially batches
of aero data that are produced by java
produced by c plus plus
and making sure that that you know both
languages agree that the data is down to
the bit level
identical uh we do have integration
tests as well and jaw
in javascript go and rust
but they're comparatively speaking less
less
feature complete than the c plus plus
and java implementations because those
have been
the projects that have attracted the
most developers
uh in the in the open source project so
far
so i understand for sure um how this
this notion and this um commitment to
forward and backward compatibility is
important especially because
um arrow is um sort of used as a
data interrupt an operation layer
between systems um
and i've seen recently that um snowflake
has adopted um
arrow internally for some some use
bigquery has adopted arrow so you must
be really excited to see
these kinds of larger projects start to
come on board
and i understand that this uh forward
backward compatibility issue is
something that's that's super important
um to remember
um along with this one point of release
yeah yeah
so for example like if you're if you are
a database vendor
um then then having forward and backward
compatibility
is is really important from from you
know
if you deploy a piece of if you deploy a
service or a server
with one version of the project like you
might not be able to roll out upgrades
to that service um for a period of years
and so
the so the you know for everyone who's
not aware
so backward compatibility means that
newer versions of the library can
understand data produced by older
versions
whereas forward compatibility means that
older library versions can detect
that features are being used that they
don't understand from the future so if
we add something
to the format that we have the ability
to communicate that we're using
uh some new unknown feature to the past
or if we're not
you know or if we're not using any new
features then we can be
assured that we're producing data that
can be consumed by
a library that's you know two or three
years old
so if you roll out like a database um
and it doesn't get upgraded for two
years and it
allows you to you know import and export
data in arrow format you aren't going to
have any
system crashes or like it isn't going to
be interpreted as being some
you know being interpreted incorrectly
by the database
so you've called aero a collaboration
between
database systems and data science
ecosystems
um can you elaborate on that what
exactly does that mean
yeah well uh so so for me the the reason
i got involved in the project was
because
i was uh i started working at cloudera
at the end of 2000 uh 2014 they
they acquired my startup datapad so we
all joined
we all joined cloudera and my job there
was to explore deeper
integrations between python and pandas
and
the big data ecosystem and one of the
things i found was that
there was no standard way to exchange
large batches of tabular data between
different data processing engines like
database systems such as impala
or general purpose distributed computing
systems like spark
there was no standard protocol for so
let's say moving
you know 100 megabytes or a gigabyte of
data at high speed
so that struck me as like uh again
something that was missing from
from the ecosystem another another
problem
was that the absence of
a standard data representation meant
that there also
were not are not available standard
libraries for performing
um database operations so if you look at
the internals of pandas like pandas
implements all of its own
algorithms for doing database operations
like
grouped aggregations joins filtering
sorting like all of that all that stuff
that
is very similar to things that you would
find inside a sql database and pandas we
had to
implement entirely ourselves and so
so part of the so one purpose of arrow
is to have a standard
like a common data layer that's language
independent that enables systems to move
around large amounts of data at the
highest
speed possible so it gets rid of data
conversions and serialization
overhead between systems but also
by by providing a standard and stable
data representation we can develop
common reusable libraries of analytics
and algorithms that perform database
operations
so we can create standard
implementations of joins or
aggregations or sorts and those can be
used in the data in the data science
world
where our algorithm algorithms that we
use are actually
relatively primitive in their
implementation or you could take the
same algorithms and build an analytic
database if you want to
so by creating like this environment
where database
engineers database developers can
collaborate with data science
people who build data science tools for
me is really exciting
and just purely at a computational level
um
the you know the the tool the algorithms
and the
computational systems that we use in
python and r
are really far behind the things that
you find on the cutting edge of the
analytic database world so
things even what was the state of the
art
10 years ago in 2010 you know thinking
about
like uh databases like vectorwise um
which uh you know that one of the
vectorwise
creators is a founder of snowflake for
example
um and uh so you know you have all
you've had all this these advances
in analytical computing for analytic
databases in the last 20 years but very
little
of that um like intellectual
like heritage from the analytic database
world has made its way
into the hands of the everyday tools
that are used for data science so
basically we just aren't getting as much
out of
our computers like out of our hardware
um
as we you know as we could and you've
you converted pandas
to the arrow format as well is that
right no
pandas has has its own internal data
representation which is
which is built using using numpy arrays
but it's not
exactly numpy and part of this is a
historic
artifact uh from uh from the origins of
pandas so back in 2008 2009 when i
was starting to build pandas having
having good interoperability with numpy
was essential for getting people to use
the project because
pandas was a brand new project and i
think now like there's plenty of people
who use pandas that don't
really know how to use numpy uh very
much at all so the
um so it's a different relationship now
versus
uh 12 13 years ago um but
that said the pandas community is in the
process of retrofitting
incrementally retrofitting pandas with
um
with optional arrow functionalities for
example using arrow to deal with strings
because we can represent a column of
string values
in pandas vastly more efficiently with
the arrow format and we can process
um you know we can process that string
data uh when it's an arrow format
in more than an order of magnitude
faster because the
error format is designed to be very
efficient on non-numeric data as well as
numeric data which is not true of
non-numeric data in
in pandas so it's certainly a process
because pandas is a 12
uh 12 year old project to make any
significant changes to the internals so
the pandas community
i mean i'm not involved in panda's
development day-to-day anymore and
haven't been for
for about seven years but um i know that
it's
it's it's like attention it's like how
like
how how fast can pandas make changes to
its internals which may
affect its users in certain esoteric
ways while also
you know innovating and improving on
performance and memory use so it's this
balancing act of like not wanting to
disrupt or harm people who are running
pandas in production while also
making progress on the on the
performance front
got it so you mentioned that um
arrow came out of some of the work that
you were doing
at cloudera when you realized the need
for these systems to
share a common or the benefit that would
occur if systems could
share a common data format um what are
some of these use cases
and who needs error most now
right so the so the the original
so the original motivation um was to was
to create
um a richer uh language language
extension
api for uh for impala which is now
apache impala which it's a distributed
analytic
analytic query engine and so databases
typically have what's called a user
defined function
api so you can write user-defined
scalar functions functions that process
one row of data at a time
and you can write analytic functions
which accumulate and
reduce a table to single values
but if you want to do some of the more
complex pandas
type operations that you would express
with the group by
apply paradigm that doesn't really fit
naturally into the um into the into the
data frame
into the to the databases uh execution
model
so we wanted to do a couple of things so
we wanted to provide
a way to write user-defined functions
with the existing apis in python and
make them efficient so
you would send a batch of data to python
and then you could run pandas code on it
and so we were trying to make that as
efficient as possible
but we also wanted it to develop like a
more like a like a better language
extension api for databases
and incidentally this is the exact same
problem that spark and pi spark has so
one of the things that we did early on
um so i moved from
from cloudera to two sigma and two sigma
you know was and is a big user of apache
spark and so
my i worked with my colleagues there my
former colleagues at two sigma along
with some folks from ibm
to build aero support into spark
for the purposes of accelerating custom
running custom python code inside spark
so now you can write use the pandas udf
interface and spark to to extend spark
sql and spark data frames with custom
pandas-based code and we were able to
get you know
in some cases like a 50x speed up by by
using arrow for the data interchange
that said spark is not aeronative and
neither is pandas so there's still
quite a bit of serialization going on
but simply by using
arrow because it's so efficient for
shuttling data around and you can
convert to and from pandas so
efficiently
we still are able to get you know a 50x
speed up in some cases
by changing from an inefficient way of
moving data to python to a more
efficient
more efficient one and the same is true
i think in general for database
drivers and database protocols that um
that they were aren't really designed
with the needs of pipe like languages
like python
and r and mine so it's very expensive to
convert from their client server
protocols to
a pandas data frame or to an r data
frame whereas
you can convert from arrow to r or arrow
to pandas
very very very very fast got it
um so i want to just take a second to
remind the audience and the listeners
that
we'll be able to take some questions for
west so if you want to type in your
questions into the chat
um we'll get to as many of them as we
can during our conversation
um so so let's let's let's dive a little
bit deeper than
um into arrow um how does arrow
work and how does arrow sort of
facilitate this
this magic across these systems
well um
so the the arrow so the arrow project is
is uh is has a few different layers so
the first thing that we built on the
project uh was we designed
a language independent memory
representation
of data frames effectively so uh
it's it's pretty nuts and bolts you can
read the specification online but it
describes the exact
bit level and byte level layout of each
uh type of data so if you have a column
of strings in a table
or a column of numbers or you could have
a column of nested types you could have
a column of structs or
lists which are called arrays and some
in some systems
um so we defined the exact memory layout
for those things
and then we developed a protocol like
what we described as a
inner process communication protocol for
arranging
um an aero batch which are called record
batches
into a byte stream so there is a
metadata prefix
which is serialized which contains the
descriptions
basically the memory locations of each
column in the
in the stream so whenever you receive a
batch of arrow data
through shared memory so if you memory
map a file that contains arrow data or
you use
operating system shared memory or if you
receive a batch of data over tcp
there's a really there's a small prefix
right at the start of the stream that
describes the entire batch so you can
resolve
all of the memory locations of the
columns in the data set
by looking at that metadata and so
basically what the arrow libraries do is
they construct data structures that
reference those memory locations so you
don't have to
move any of the data around or do any
copying or conversion when you receive
when you receive a batch of data and
because
all of the technology that we use to
build the format is not coupled to any
programming language
um we you know we can build native
libraries in
in in any language the only requirement
that uh that they have is is that they
have that they use or can interface with
an implementation of flat buffers which
is a google project
that is similar to protocol buffers but
is a bit lighter weight
and we use flat buffers only to
serialize metadata so none of the data
itself
ever touches flat buffers not so we we
have our own protocol for arranging the
you know if we have a gigabyte of data
like that's all handled outside of
flat buffers so that the flat buffers is
only used for the
the message prefix which enables a
library to understand
where to find each column in a in a data
set
so this notion of zero copy seems to be
an important
guiding principle of arrow what what are
some of the other design principles that
you followed when architecting this
protocol
um well some of the other principles in
designing the format itself
we spent a lot of time thinking about um
processing efficiency because it's not
it's not enough
to simply be able to transport the data
very quickly
we also want it to be a favorable in
memory format for processing so
if for example you load a big data set
into memory or maybe you memory map
a large data set on disk and in order to
get
good performance out of your analytics
out of your algorithms if the first
thing that you do is convert arrow to
something else
and then run your algorithms on
something else then that that doesn't
really make sense so we want to use we
want to
be we want to use arrow for data
interchange and arrow as the in-memory
representation that we code all of our
algorithms against
so we were very careful in we were very
careful in thinking about
how to make sure that you can iterate
through
a data set uh without having cache
misses on the cpu
um that the let the memory layout of
strings is sufficient to process for
example
um and that you can do efficient uh
transformations of schemas like you can
select columns out of a table
or you could uh unnest a nested
structure and select
fields out of a struct or out of some
other nested structure without doing any
any data copying we also wanted arrow to
run well on
non you know non cpus so on gpus for
example
and so we've seen people doing using
arrow both on gpus and
fpgas and so notably the
nvidia rapids project qdf uses arrow as
its data representation
for representing data on the gpu and you
know they recently
published a set of benchmarks where they
completely destroyed the
uh you know the state-of-the-art in in
big data benchmarks
um all using codif and das for
distributed orchestration
and they were able to get uh 20 20 times
performance improvement
um at one-third the amount of power
usage so if you think about like the
amount of data
you know the amount of data processed
per kilowatt hour that's a 60x
i guess it's 3x improvement in power
utilization and 20x improvement in
performance so it's
it's pretty uh pretty impressive
and so um arrow is optimized for
columnar type operations is that a a
good way to think about it yes
yeah so it's it's uh it's it's oriented
around
columnar vectorized query processing
um so it's uh
yeah so if you if you have an algorithm
that that needs to go
uh row by row and visit all of the
columns in a
in a data set that's the worst that's
the worst case scenario for a
scenario for arrow but that's that's a
well-known kind of trade-off between
row-based systems and columnar-based
systems
and in the database literature there's
been
there's been some study of the
trade-offs between columnar
systems versus versus row-based systems
and in recent years with as llvm has
become a mature technology for
for a runtime code generation it's
become
a lot more practical to build high
performance
row-based database systems because based
on the structure of the query that you
write
you generate um you generate custom code
that is specific to that data schema
to perform various operations whereas
in vectorized systems and that are
columnar
they don't need to take they don't
necessarily need to use
things like runtime code generation
because you're
making a decision about which algorithm
to call um
kind of at the at the vector level kind
of at the column level so
you you say okay i'm going to call this
pre-compiled function on this column
and it processes the whole the whole
column chunk in a single
in a single go rather than having to you
know having to inline logic with a
with a custom compiler
so um on that note i know sometimes
folks get
maybe um slightly confused between
when to use arrow and when to use
parquet
even though they're obviously different
technologies they support um
certain types of com columnar notions
can you explain the relationship if
there's any between the two
yeah so uh and importantly
um some of the same some of the same uh
designers of parquet
are uh helped to design help design
arrow as well
so julian ledem is the main arc you know
one of the main architects of parquet
uh and he and i worked closely in the
early days of
in the early days of arrow so arrow and
parquet were always intended to be
companion technologies
you can use arrow to store data so part
parquez
is exclusively for date of storage um
it is not a runtime data format so when
you read a parquet file
you have to decode it and then put the
data somewhere
and so the arrow format is intended to
be that
somewhere that you put the data when
it's read out of a parquet file
and if you look at other databases like
if you look at database systems that use
parquet
typically they end up with their like a
custom parquet implementation
that's optimized for loading parquet
files
into the databases native
native and memory representation
that said there are more and more people
that are using arrow for storage
so if you are working on
if you have a if you're working locally
on a machine that has a solid state
drive you can write an arrow data set to
disk and then memory map it
and then process it as though it were in
memory because the on disk
representation is the same as the
in-memory representation
we did recently add um simple
compression for storing
uh for storing arrow and sending data um
over the over the wire like so if you
were sending data
over tcp which i i think we'll talk a
bit more later
in the stream um you might want to
compress it
using lz4 or zstd which are two new
state-of-the-art
compression codecs and you get by
spending a little more cpu time
compressing the data you can get better
end-to-end performance because
um you know if you're on a gigabit
gigabit network you can only move
data at you know 128 megabytes per
second so
compressing it will give you better you
know you can the the bottleneck is your
network so if you make the data smaller
your whole application goes faster
so we have a bunch of questions coming
in wes um
let's take a couple matthew is asking is
it possible and advisable to use arrow
directly
in a in a native data intensive
application
instead of using aero indirectly by a
db-like
application yes yeah absolutely so
so one of the things that so what we've
a lot of what we've been doing the last
four and a half years in the open source
project is creating
a development platform for you to build
custom
data processing applications that use
arrow so like we do intend
for you to choose one of those libraries
that is
the language that you prefer to use so
if you're using cpus plus or you're
using java
you can install the the arrow libraries
and use um their it's like in cpus plus
we have built like a pretty
comprehensive
development platform that contains like
an i o subsystem
like a file system subsystem you can use
the libraries to interact with amazon s3
for example
um we have like pretty sophisticated
tools for
memory allocation and dealing with um
like you know like remember like memory
like managing memory lifetime so if you
allocate some memory and then split it
up into pieces
um the system can you know can reason
that there's still like a lingering
reference to a piece of memory and
prevent it from
being deallocated so so we built the
libraries um
intending for people to use them
directly to build custom data
applications and not
not just for people to build databases
and then for other people to just use
those databases
but you can use you can use the
libraries to build a database if you
want
another question alessandro is asking
pi arrow currently has a reader for orc
files but not a writer is there any plan
to add a writer anytime soon
uh people have people have asked for it
um
i know that i i guess my you know my
ursa labs team
uh it isn't a pr it isn't a priority for
my team in
in the short term but it's uh
um it would be a good um so part of it
so
so part of part of the issue is that
there
in the past there was not a c
plus based orc or c writer
and so we implemented or we received a
contribution from anaconda actually of
an orc reader and since then the the
writer in c
plus has matured and we're waiting for
a volunteer to um emerge
to implement the writer uh you know
implement the aero writer interface
um so it's you know it's probably a
solid uh
you know a few weeks of work at least
for for a motivated developer but as
soon as we have
uh a writer in c plus plus for the
format we could expose it pretty easily
and
and pi and python through pi arrow
got it uh matthew is also asking
is the memory model of arrow pneuma
aware
um it's
it's it's not something that we it's
so so for people that don't so people
that don't know so numa has to do with
with servers that have multiple uh
multiple cpu sockets
it's not an issue that we deal with
directly in the library so it's
something that
it's something that your application
that your application will have to
reason about so for example
like we provide a in the cpus plus
libraries we provide a device api
which enables us to reason about like
what like where a piece of memory is
located so we can distinguish between
memory being on one of the gpus in the
system
versus being in cpu memory
but having not done development on a
multi-multi-socket system
a multi-socket system myself i'm not
aware of the particular nuances of what
what we could reasonably provide in the
in the libraries that would help
that would help with that it would
probably be something that your
application would have to deal with on
its own
um one more os chuck is asking anything
worth mentioning regarding the
representation
of any values in arrow any design
challenges or trade-offs
i see a null type has no physical
storage in the api
um
any values is uh i guess i'm i'm maybe
having oh and parsing
and and a values oh i see i see
oh uh well all all all data types in
in arrow are nullable and have
and use the same um data representation
for representing null so there's an
accompanying
bitmap where when a bit is set so
there's one bit per value
um so we we pack we have a packed bitmap
and so when a bit is set that means that
the value is not
null and when the bit is not set it
means it's null
and one of the benefits of using the
using the bitmap representation is that
we can
we can use hardware operations to count
set bits in a run of values and then
determine whether or not we need to do
null checking when we're performing an
algorithm so
when you don't need to check each value
whether it's null
which is the case actually with pandas
and with r for example
you get way better performance because
the cpu doesn't have to do branching
at the at the cell level in the array
so we're pretty happy with that choice
and it's consistent with
the way that a lot of database systems
work got it
well um i want to make sure we have some
time to chat about
flight um because flight is
uh something that is is really
interesting in terms of
bringing some distributed systems like
capabilities or power um to the aero
framework
um so do you want to explain to us what
flight is less and
and why that's a big deal yeah so
uh so flight is a um flight is a project
that
um that you know my team and i have been
collaborating on closely with with
dremeo
and uh and two sigma to build a
general purpose framework for
implementing aero
native data services it's built
one layer above above grpc
which is google's rpc and messaging
library and
so what we did was we provide a
command layer for implementing a service
so if you
if you are a server that wants to
receive commands and then return
arrow data sets as the as the result of
those commands
flight is a is a library which enables
you to implement such a service
and what we've done is we've dealt with
the low-level integration with grpc
so such that you as a developer only
have to think about
arrow data and we handle the the details
of transporting it efficiently over grpc
so we did some low level stuff
with grpc to avoid memory copies and
serialization
and we've been able to to achieve uh
really impressive
end-to-end uh performance and
scalability
uh through grpc so a single thread
um in flight can can deliver data end to
end
at well over you know well over two
two gigabytes sometimes over three
gigabytes per second
um over over tcp that's of course on
localhost so there's no
impact of network of network transfer
speeds
but when you consider that that's you
know end-to-end moving data from one
process to another
that you can only really achieve that
level of performance when you
aren't having to serialize there's no
data conversions at all so we send
we send a byte stream and that byte
stream is in
reinterpreted as an aero data set
on the other side so we're really
excited in particular about using flight
as a replacement for
the database type protocols that people
have been using for the last
20 or 30 years so things like odpc and
jdbc
which are pretty standard but they're
they're inefficient to the api that they
provide
um is pretty inefficient for loading
data into
um loading data into things like pandas
data frames or r data frames
whereas you can load data from arrow
very efficiently so
um so we're anxious to see database
vendors and and data systems in general
implement flight
um because it you know makes delivering
data to data scientists significantly
faster and you have only one
if you have a flight client you can
interact with a flight service
and you only have one um you know way of
accessing data to
to uh to think about
um that said there are other companies
that have been using arrow
with but not flight as a way to
accelerate their database clients so
for example snowflake and bigquery have
both used arrow
but not necessarily flight to implement
to implement their uh to accelerate
their their clients
but that's partly because their clients
are not based on grpc
so we uh but you know grpc is a good
choice
if you're building a standalone service
that needs to process
a high volume of requests and be really
reliable because it's
literally the transport framework that
powers a lot of google
and so in order for someone to use grpc
what's
what's happening under the covers that's
that's
implement it's an implementation of
protobufs in some way is that
is that right no so so uh
um so grpc uh allows you to
allows you to write to implement grpc
services
using um using the the protocol buffers
language
so you can write down so they they have
some extensions for protocol buffers and
then a plug-in for the
protobuf compiler that will generate the
grpc
service dubs but grpc itself as a
framework doesn't
doesn't understand protocol buffers it's
it's
agnostic to the the data serialization
format
it's easiest to use to use grpc when you
use it with protocol buffers because
that's also
you know google's preferred data
serialization format that they use
internally
um but uh so we did we defined flight as
a
grpc protocol buffers based definition
and we use protobuf for the
representation of all of the commands
that are sent
in flight but then we implemented some
custom
um serializers quote unquote that step
in
in between the protocol the grpc and the
protobuf library
to prevent any unnecessary data copies
from being
from being made but if you if you were
to interact with
if you were to be aware of a flight
service and all you have at your
disposal
is grpc you and the service definition
for flight you could still interact with
the flight service without having even
an arrow library so
that was important to us that we didn't
want like we wanted people to still be
able to
use the service and issue it commands
without necessarily having a full aero
library at their disposal
and how is the adoption of flight been
so far
what are you most excited about flight
enabling
teams and engineers to do in the future
well flight is really is really about um
is a couple of things so it's it's about
enabling data applications and data
scientists to get
access to data faster and more
efficiently
because they're using this much more
efficient
protocol for accessing accessing
services
it's also simpler because if you have if
you go from
a world of having to use multiple
different client libraries to
access different data services so if
somebody puts a flight front end in
front of
a data service then you don't have to
think about like oh which client do i
use to interact with this
vendor service and so you can use the
same
client the same flight client library to
access many different data services
from the standpoint of the data
engineers or the data platform folks
flight also makes their lives better
because they you know can standardize on
a common way of implementing providing a
service front end
for for data access um and by using
flight
because it means more efficient uh
more efficient transport of data that
the services so the person maintaining
the service will get better
resource utilization will be able to
hire
handle a higher volume of requests and
handle more data requests using the same
amount of hardware so that also
lowers the cost of operating the data
infrastructure which
of course the person who paying the aws
or the jcp or azure bill will be very
happy about
for sure um and so where can people
find more info about flight plus
well that we have we we published a blog
post um
last fall um like
we've you know people been aware of the
project we've been working on it for
for about two years now but um we
launched it to
the beta effectively last fall so
there's a blog on arrow.apache.org
that introduces flight um i've given a
number of talks recently where i've gone
deeper into
um deeper into flight so i spoke at
uh dremeo's um subsurface
virtual conference and my talk there was
about it was about flight so you can
look up
there's my video for that is on youtube
and my slide decks you can check
you can check that out um and dremeo
because drumeo is an aero
aero native um query engine and data
lake engine
and they are they are working on
delivering flight natively as
a way of interacting with um with dremeo
so i'm excited to see that go to
production and for dremeo
users to be able to um to use dremeo
to build their applications rather than
having to go through jdbc or odbc
which is a lot slower great
well um i want to shift gears a little
bit and
take the conversation in a slightly
different direction because
um wes you and i have had chats over the
years about just the open source
ecosystem
in general and um being that you've been
so involved as a
instigator an author a committer a
leader
of several projects now that have been
very meaningful for many many folks and
have sort of
touched the lives of data science and
analytics professionals
everywhere i know that you've spent a
lot of time thinking about
the sustainability of open source the
economics of open source
um how to measure the success of an open
source project
um how to get the community riled up and
sort of all of these softer things
around
what it takes to really launch and
manage and
be effective at open source that you've
given a lot of
um a lot of thoughts to over the years
so
i'm just curious like maybe as a way to
back into that
um for you right now how do you measure
the success
of a project like arrow for instance
like what things are you
sort of watching for in terms of kpis or
um how are you as a as a author and a
a promoter of this project how are you
measuring success um
right now how do you think about that
you know i mean there's
there's a number of there's a number of
dimensions to look at
so i mean one you know one obvious one
is is to the extent that you can measure
project downloads um that's
i think that's that's a helpful that's a
helpful metric to see whether
the software is being used so the fact
that um
you know we've seen exponential growth
in um
the number of installs of the aero
packages has been
uh has been great um so like arrows
being installed about a third as many
times as pandas
so that's you know pretty significant
adoption considering
pandas is you know one of the most most
installed python packages scientific
python packages
after after numpy which everything
depends on
i think something that people don't
appreciate as much as community growth
so if you had a really popular project
that only has a handful of
contributors that becomes a big a big
liability because it means that the
number of stakeholders
like developers stakeholders in the
project isn't very high relative to the
project's importance
and so in in aero one something that
we've i think my team and i have spent a
disproportionate amount of time
is growing and supporting the developer
ecosystem around the project
so part of that is making the project
easier easier to contribute to and to
provide
more systems that support developer
productivity
so like automation in ci
and packaging um like testing
like because there's not everything we
can't test everything on every commit
um but there's a lot of things that we
do want to give people to be able to
test on demand
so like we've built um like an on-demand
um like like a job executor for
for testing various odd corners of the
project and that's helped that's all
integrated in github and has helped
people a lot
i guess another metric is just looking
at industry adoption of the project
so um you know we've like i've spent a
lot of time
on outreach to different companies that
are that we see that are using arrow or
considering using arrow
and working with them to help make sure
that they're
uh successful using the project because
if we build the software and then
you know people using it at scale or
having a difficult time then
there's some you know we need to change
our priorities
um so i think when i've you know very
deliberately
in in setting up ursa labs and defining
our relationship with um the companies
that sponsor our work um
you know kind of wanted to create this
symbiotic relationship between
a group of open source maintainers and
companies like we've been working with
hardware companies like intel and nvidia
we've also our users and contributors
to the project as well as a number of
financial institutions so two sigma
which has been funding the project for
over four years now
on some other institutions that are
using aero like like bloomberg for
example
uh is using the project for various
things um so they've been sponsoring
sponsoring us and some other uh some
other financial firms as well
um so that's been a i think a good
working model in that
like we want to create like uh so you
know we
so like we act as as facilitators
for um for getting work done in the
project and making sure
that the you know corporate stakeholders
so people that are using the project in
production that their needs are being
looked
after in the project or if they have
people
engineers that are contributing that
we're helping them you know get prompt
code reviews and get their work into the
project
um but it's yeah it's definitely a
thorny problem i will say that you know
given how
important arrow has become in terms of
um
improving performance and efficiency in
people's data infrastructure i think
that's
definitely made our lives easier in
terms of sponsorship
and sponsorship for for the work um
you know compared with you know i think
sometimes open source developers
like aren't nearly so like um aren't
nearly
aren't that close maybe to like a cost
center
in an organization so because when
people adopt aerial their computing
costs go down
and their applications get faster and so
there's it's a lot easier for a company
to measure
the roi of making
you know making aero better whereas
other open source projects like the
connection between
cost or or productivity may not be
nearly so clear and so in those cases
that's where it's really difficult
for you know if you go to say ask us an
organization for
ten thousand dollars or fifty thousand
dollars to sponsor development
it may be hard for them to really judge
whether or not there's good roi for them
to to sponsor um sponsor at that level
so it's difficult and i think we you
know we also have to
to make sure that we're doing a good job
of communicating the value add of the
project
and explain kind of how like our vision
for what we're doing
is is related to like the goals that
that
that you know that the industry has in
their data infrastructure
well i have to say um you know
personally speaking i
i understand um from the perspective of
another
founder investing in building data
community
you know data council is not sort of
writing bits and
designing software like you are but
we're still in the business of creating
community around the data ecosystem
transferring knowledge um and sort of
getting engineers and data scientists
set up in order to be able to meet each
other share with each other
discover each other interact with each
other etc and so
we have sort of this unique notion of
being a stand-alone third-party
community that's not tied on to any one
vendor and you know the the way that
we've been able to monetize that is
through
events and conferences and that was
really the most viable business model
that we could come up with but
it's a little bit odd to be a
stand-alone community oriented
organization
um that basically has to rely on
corporate sponsors
maybe maybe it's not odd it's just sort
of the the only way i've figured out how
to do it but i feel like
you've sort of mirrored that in terms of
like embracing this quote sponsorship
model
with open source um do you think that
that will work for
other projects i mean i guess you
already mentioned sort of some of the
challenges with
um whether or not there's a close tie to
the the value prop
um have you seen any other open source
projects
um start to sort of approach it from
this this angle
yeah i mean i recognize that i recognize
that we're
um i recognize that we are in a in a in
a somewhat unique
uh unique situation so like the thing
that
i think the thing that really has made
has made ursa labs work for example is
our relationship with
with our studio which has been providing
um the majority of our funding and all
of the administrative
support for the team and so their
motivation um
is not only to improve interoperability
and synergies between
python and r so a lot of data
organizations use both languages
together
but you know our studio became um at the
beginning of the year a public benefit
corporation and part of their
public benefit is investing back in
in the growth and sustainability of data
science tools and so
their sponsorship of aero development is
about doing good in the world through
through better through better tools and
so i recognize that the same sort the
same kind of path is not going to be
available to
to a lot of open source projects because
there's not a lot of companies like
rstudio around unfortunately i hope to
see more
companies with a mission that's aligned
with
you know public good and building open
source software
but i think it's more typical that you
see
you know companies selling either
building an enterprise support business
or doing more consulting or making money
through
i think organizing um i know in the
early days of
in the early days of data breaks uh you
know i think
i think the the spark spark summits and
spark conferences
um were a you know good source of
revenue for
you know companies like data bricks in
the early days and i think that's been
true some of the other
open source you know companies that it's
good for
building the community and um and sort
of exchanging ideas but
but you as kind of a community
facilitator and
creating like this environment for cross
cross pollination like that has a lot of
value and so
if that enables you to um also
you know to uh sort of continue to do
more community development
or in some with some companies that are
you know able to fund
developers to um to build the open
source projects that they're had that
they're organizing conferences for i
mean that's that's fantastic
so but it's definitely very challenging
because there isn't really an efficient
way to
to extract sponsorship from from
organizations like
to me the the you know the ultimate
solution
to funding open source development would
be through uh would be through taxation
so basically taxing corporate profits
because
you think about like what like what is
all this open source
innovation uh yielded for the economy
like the world economy and so
businesses are able to achieve such
massive scale and such massive impact
through all of this
all this technology which has been made
built and made available for free on the
internet
and so if a company you know it's hard
to measure exactly well how much of a
company's profit
has been boosted by you know their use
of open source but
you know if if if we under if we
undercut it if we uh
if we uh mis-estimate by maybe a factor
of 100 and we tax just a little bit of
corporate profits
and we use that to fund um you know to
fund open source developers i think that
seems
okay to me you know maybe we can buy a
few like us we can buy fewer uh fighter
jets or something like that and we can
have
um you know happier uh open source
developers that are able to but it's
like it's it's sort of it's a bit
short-sighted that the
that you know that the us government and
other
other world governments um haven't
really incorporated
like the support of open source
infrastructure into their
into their budgeting because really like
free
freely available like and you know
sustained innovation and open source
makes businesses more successful and so
which is going to increase corporate
profits and then
fund and then fund the government so a
little i think a little bit of
of uh investment from uh from from the
governments would go a long way
in in terms of making the making the
ecosystem more sustainable so i will
keep hoping that that will occur
in uh in my lifetime at least but
you know with the way that things are
going uh you know not just in the united
states it
i could be waiting a long time well
maybe there's there's uh other newer
licensing
options as well that become
more prominent or recognized as sort of
being the need to support the open
source world i know there's some
innovation and
a bunch of people thinking about that as
well
awesome wes well um thank you for for
joining us
um just in terms of a final question um
since our time is up i just wanted to
ask you what's the most surprising thing
you've learned
in the last few years especially
building arrow
the most surprising thing um
[Laughter]
um i i will say like around i think i
think one of the
things i that i didn't understand as
well
um a few years ago was that
i kind of around the open source
economics question
um was that probably the biggest barrier
to corporations funding open source is
the way that they budget
and so because there is not a clear like
a clean
line item in people's budgets for
sponsoring open source
that makes it difficult for um
for you know whoever is uh you know
responsible for
or interested in sponsoring a project
they don't have like an obvious place
like you know to to put it whereas
like you know people have huge budgets
to pay for computers or to pay for cloud
computing
or to pay for enterprise software but
there's no like
you know people are not yet in a point
where they are out you know they're
um you know they're reserving you know
even one-tenth of one percent of their
i.t budget to fund
to sponsor open source now and so it
wasn't
as apparent to me that that was a
problem until i started going out to
uh to look for sponsorships um and then
people would say oh well you know we
don't know where the money's going to
come from
and then you say well you're a very rich
company you know
clearly you know you find enough money
between the seat cushions but it's
it turns out it's not that simple
well that's well said and for those of
us who are starting companies or
um or who have management um uh budget
budgetary availability in terms of rit
operations i think that's
definitely worthwhile considering and
appreciate all of your work with the
community over the years i know it's
been
hard for you sometimes to figure out
how to how to make a living doing this
and so i salute you for
all those years that i've known you
since 2012 and
all the work that you've done um the
companies that you've joined
the drums that you've that you've beat
just to sort of make this issue aware
for all of us
and so i hope that this is a continued
wake-up call to folks that we need more
economic support for open source and
it probably does lie mostly with the
companies who have the
means if not the budget allocated at
least they have the means to sort of fix
that problem and
and start to figure out ways to support
any full open source projects that they
use every day
well thanks thanks for joining us wes um
this has been fun it's uh
great to see you and i'm looking forward
to
more updates on arrow and and flight
along the way
yeah thanks thanks pete for uh for
having me
all right